when someone else is doing my makeup I'm
just like you'd do it you know exactly
what you're doing yeah well you don't
end up looking like a clown I'm gonna be
distracting them a conversation to make
sure they don't know they're being
pranked I'm super excited to see what I
look like as Kylie Jenner she has some
really good selfies lots of confidence
which I love so this would be my first
official makeover for Michelle I'm gonna
hook her up with some raccoon eyes and
some cat whiskers for Jade we're gonna
give her a nice extreme orange tan I was
thinking of repositioning her eyebrows
for Mallory she has a very joyful face
so I'm gonna make her into a clown
I can like tell there's stuff on my face
like I have this extra kind of layer but
it's not anything crazy like I can
understand how people would get used to
it oh oh oh what wait wait no what is it
oh my gosh I kind of look like a pumpkin
that's insane wait this is what she does
why do I look like a raccoon I think the
only thing I like is the lipstick so
maybe I'll snag that but my face is a
totally different color than the rest of
my body she what I don't get it oh well
coz I don't want info Kylie Jenner I was
like oh my god does she have to do this
every day
I'm keeping the lashes I am gonna take
the rest of this off and leave that I'm
really glad this isn't real I'm
terrified of clowns on a normal basis so
I look I was like oh god you haven't
seen already in that movie